one of the biggest flash points in the
2016 presidential election came around
records records retention
emails email servers
responsibility with classified and
sensitive information all directed
at hillary clinton remember that this
was the biggest storyline about hillary
clinton she would be in jail trump said
if i was president because of what she
did with emails and documents and so on
and so forth
every day now i'm not exaggerating every
day just over the weekend each day there
was another major story about the trump
white house and records and we have
we're going to look at two of those
stories now and the first is that
essentially a raid took place on
mar-a-lago
where the national archives showed up
to get trump's documents
many of which related to meetings with
north korean dictator kim jong-un
remember those love letters remember
trump said and we fell in love
trump did not turn over the records
to the national archives he took him to
mar-a-lago and the national archives had
to go down there and get the records
this is an incredible story uh
washington post reporters
jacqueline alemany josh dossey and
others
reporting president trump improperly
removed multiple boxes from the white
house that were retrieved by the
national archives last month from his
mar-a-lago residents he just took the
documents home
because they contained documents and
other items that should have been turned
over to the agency according to three
people familiar with a visit
the recovery of the boxes from trump's
florida resort raises new concerns about
his adherence to the presidential
records act which requires the
preservation of memos letters notes
emails faxes and other written
communications related to a president's
official duties trump advisors deny any
nefarious intent of course and say the
boxes contain mementos gifts
letters from world leaders
who could not realize
that those are presidential records and
other correspondence the items included
correspondence with north korean leader
kim jong-un which trump once described
as love letters and then we fell in love
right
right
as well as a letter left for his
successor by president barack obama
according to two people familiar with
the contents discussions between the
archives and the former president's
lawyers that began last year resulted in
the transfer of the records in january
another person familiar with the
materials said trump advisers discussed
what had to be returned in december
people familiar with the transfer spoke
on the condition of anonymity so in
december they explained to trump what
needed to be returned
and uh
it took
uh the national archives showing up
later to actually get the stuff
the archives have struggled to cope with
the president who flouted there it is
guys see i told you it's a real word
people always say when i say flouted
david don't you mean flaunt it and i say
no i mean flouted a president who
flouted document retention requirements
and frequently ripped up official
documents leaving hundreds of pages
taped back together so
um
this is uh
this story and we're going to talk about
the incineration of documents in a
moment
this is the prototypical backwards
projection scam that was this entire
presidency the story in 2016 was
hillary's gonna do bad stuff with
records hillary can't be trusted with
email
uh documents classified secret sensitive
and since trump has left
we found out that the real concern
around all of those things was donald
trump and his kids and other people that
worked for him do we think hillary would
have eaten documents as donald trump
allegedly did no
do we think hillary would have ripped
documents and tossed them onto the floor
and then people run in and grab the
scraps and tape them back together of
course not do we think hillary would
have taken documents about foreign
policy meetings and letters from foreign
leaders to her house
give me a break guys and we can argue
about anything else about hillary versus
trump that's fine
but on this issue which was the flash
point about why hillary can't be trusted
trump's the guy that we need to worry
about
uh i would love to hear more about the
retrieval that took place and this is
not the only story about trump and white
house records that we have today the
next story relates to incineration
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you twenty percent off monk
packs keto nut and seed bars which taste
just like your favorite sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10 percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as i do they will
refund you all your money i think
there's a really good chance
monk pack nut and seed bars become your
favorite go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout